ein klub voller menschen
seit corona so verboten auch in
barcelona in spanien
die polizei passt auf wir sind dorthin
gereist wir das sind sebastian und alica
weil wir wissen wollten wie und wo
illegal gefeiert wird wer sind die
menschen die dort tanzen wie
funktioniert das während corona muss
eigentlich ständig um nachweise und
tests geht
kann man einer stadt die von partys lebt
überhaupt das feiern verbieten
[Musik]
aktuell sind die bekannten beach-clubs
näher
normalerweise ist es hier so
richtig krass
die party dann kannst du außerdem gibt's
direkt ins meer gehen und so kann ich
ganz geil aber im moment halt nix
am abend sind wir bei bekannten zu einer
hausparty eingeladen
wir treffen hier freunde aus meiner
studienzeit
sowie adria
er nimmt uns mit zu seinen freunden sie
sind inzwischen alle geimpft trauen sich
wieder sich in größeren gruppen zu
treffen auch mit neuen fremden leuten
die mit
[Musik]
barcelona ist eigentlich dafür bekannt
dass hier menschen aus ganz europa
zusammen feiern sowie slawen der
eigentlich aus serbien kommt oder chris
neben ihm aus großbritannien heute soll
alles mal wieder sein wie früher
[Musik]
unbeschwert und ausgelassen
bevor die nächste heftige corona welle
anrollt und sie alle wieder zu hause
bleiben müssen
ganz ehrlich irgendwann bist du an einem
punkt du willst niemand anderen
verletzten aber du willst auch wieder
deine freiheit und spaß haben es ist ein
balance-akt und wirklich nicht einfach
zu entscheiden
je mehr die regierung inzwischen
einschränkt desto mehr umwege werden
gefunden
du findest immer einen ort meist
illegale plätze in privatwohnungen oder
am ende machen kannst was du willst
die illegalen orte sind im aufschwung
wir wollen wissen wie das genau
funktioniert wer organisiert die partys
und wie kommt man rein
besonders in zeiten wie diesen ist alles
sehr spontan
es gibt keinen genauen plan alles ist
sehr geheim niemand macht dafür werbung
und du musst die orte einfach suchen
kriegs kontakte aber keine werbung oder
so slawen hat unsere namen über einen
kontakt auf eine liste gesetzt
ich kenne die adresse aber ich wurde
darum gebeten sie nicht an alle
weiterzugeben
sie haben gesagt sie teilen sie kurz vor
der party mit das war die offizielle
bitte
es geht ihnen aber nicht um den kick
oder darum etwas verbotenes zu tun
ich glaube die regierung sollte auch
hier einen plan haben sowie andere
länder wie zb kroatien oder serbien wo
es partys gibt wo sie im vorfeld testen
das ist doch besser hier gibt es so was
nicht es ist einfach alles zu das wird
menschen dazu bringen zu rebellieren
nach eineinhalb jahren sind sie langsam
mürbe
das problem ist noch im märz/april
dachten sich viele leute okay noch drei
monate aber dann im sommer kann ich
wieder machen was ich will das wurde uns
zumindest gesagt der große unterschied
ist jetzt sind fast alle in meiner
familie geimpft fast alle die ich kenne
das risiko ist nun also geringer es gibt
zwar neue varianten aber der sinn der
impfung ist ja dass das risiko weniger
ist
danke dass ihr da seid ich wünsche mir
dass wir noch mehr solcher momente
erleben ich habe euch alle so gern das
war's
nicht jede wird an diesem abend mit
kommen zur party doch alle sind sich
einig sie wollen endlich wieder spaß
haben
wenn ich eine strafe bekomme dann zahle
ich sie aber ich muss mich selbst
endlich wieder ein bisschen gehen lassen
können ich arbeite so viel weil tanzen
trinken und ausgehen gilt als böse aber
arbeiten geld verdienen und zu hause
arbeiten nicht aber ein freier
glücklicher mensch zu sein schon so
fühlt es sich zumindest für mich an also
denke ich mir okay gibt mir eine strafe
bestraft mich damit ich glücklich sein
kann
dann geht es los slaven hat die uhr im
blick vor mitternacht müssen wir da sein
deshalb muss es jetzt schnell gehen
wow was für ein organisations desaster
du bist der anführer nein aber ich muss
zuerst da sein dann gehe ich einfach und
es ist nicht mehr mein problem
dann geht es mit dem taxi aus 20 minuten
an den stadtrand
es ist das erste mal dass er mit einer
großen gruppe irgendwie unterwegs sind
und hier fahren jetzt hier raus an den
stadtrand von barcelona
in das turnier
wenn es noch nicht so richtig für das
aussieht
das hat das die tore zu gemacht werden
dass wir dabei müssen vor weil dann in
die herzen bis 6
an einer straßenecke treffen wir die
anderen wieder alle sind ein bisschen
aufgeregt wie beim allerersten club
besuch
dann stehen wir schon vor einem
unauffälligen tor und sind auch schon
drin
wie in einem ganz normalen club werden
gästelisten namen abgehakt abkassiert
zehn euro pro person und getränkebons
verkauft corona kontrollen gibt es hier
aber nicht
und so sieht es nun aus zwei etagen und
den dancefloor
um die bar sofas und auf eine schaukel
[Musik]
unten sind die djs lauter elektromusik
und rund 200 leute wie heiß aufs tanzen
sind
masten trägt niemand es wird geschwitzt
gefeiert vergessen wie es ist da draußen
im alltag mit corona
[Musik]
so vergehen die stunden bis um 6 uhr
morgens das licht wieder angeht und wir
sind plötzlich genauso schnell wieder
draußen wie wir zuvor hier rein geraten
sind
[Applaus]
gleichzeitig mache ich natürlich auch
wir menschen in einem raum mit so vielen
bereich ewig nicht mehr in einem raum
insofern es ist schön und wird den
beruflich gleichzeitig tatsächlich
etwas was früher normal war fühlt sich
heute unsicher für uns an in einem raum
mit vielen menschen seien ohne tests
ohne masken ohne kontrollen wer weiß ob
sich das jemals wieder richtig liegt
[Musik]